[Musique]
avec 750 millions d'habitants et 46 ans
après son indépendance l'Inde est la
plus grande démocratie du monde
ce voyage en Inde nous l'avons commencé
au bord de la Seine lors du grand mais
là ouvrant l'année de l'Inde en France
c'était en juin dernier
nous le poursuivrons en compagnie des
Indiens qui vivent en région parisienne
en quelque sorte entre Ganges et scène
[Musique]
vous verrez nous allons entrer dans un
univers qui nous semble bien connu
l'Inde est à la mode périodiquement mais
depuis si longtemps que nous pensons
tout savoir du continent indien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en réalité les images que les Indiens
nous donnent de même sont une politesse
qu'il nous faut et une manière de nous
dire que peut-être quelque part notre
sensibilité n'est plus assez affiner
pour pénétrer leur monde intérieur
[Musique]
depuis les anciens dieux de l'Himalaya
vénéré encore par les Hindous l'un d' a
connu la révolution bouddhiste depuis
l'islam et toutes les autres aventures
spirituelles jusqu'à serait au robindo
célébrés ici par scridinaire fondateur
de la Théophile
à un moment en Europe puis nationaliste
il s'opposa à Gandhi le non violent dans
la conduite de l'Inde vers
l'indépendance la France comme l'Inde
est ouverte à tous les courants
[Musique]
majoritaire ici les Français ils
viennent des anciens comptoirs
Pondichéry Mahé carical nous allons
française le plus souvent catholique
c'est Jean choisis les DOM-TOM ou la
métropole puisque la langue officielle
en Inde reste l'anglais souvent
fonctionnaire ou commerçants nous les
avons rencontrés monsieur Valmy valmyse
la somme comme République s'est installé
dans le passage Brady où il est en train
de réussir
nous sommes là près de deux superbes
gravures je croyais que vous étiez
catholique je suis catholique
parce que nous sommes bien des Inde
alors je suis à Antoine
depuis qu'il est arrivé ici j'ai
commencé faire un Morgan boutique j'ai
mis un nom de Dieu c'est-à-dire Morgane
c'est fils de Siva alors
j'ai commencé un petit avec ça
maintenant il y avait plaisir boutique
vous êtes en France depuis quand depuis
1978 madame et vous êtes venus pourquoi
je veux venir avec mon ambassadeur
l'ambassade de France c'était départ
l'arrivée par nos délire
j'ai travaillé avec l'ambassadeur ici
pendant un an qu'est-ce que vous faisiez
je suis cuisinier
c'est mon métier c'est à cause de
cousines français j'ai commencé faire
des restaurants indiens vous avez fait
venir une partie de votre famille ici
pour l'instant
c'est un peu près 100 ans de personnes
déjà depuis 15 ans il s'en rentrés c'est
hier dans le métier c'est nationalité
française de Pondichéry
j'ai commencé par camionnette je
présente des films indou dans la salle
de cinéma il y a l'arrivée de nombreux
de indiens même pas de chérien de Sri
Lanka et pas beaucoup vous arrivez un
peu près 25 personnes à peu près 1972
dans la salle de cinéma j'ai vendu les
pots de courir 50 g 100 g par exemple
l'amener de Pondichéry 5 kg 10 kg j'ai
commencé par ça alors maintenant
j'achète même à Z 5 tonnes 10 tonnes de
prix
se vend très vite aussi qu'est-ce que
vous trouvez que vous êtes plus heureux
ici que Pondichéry
faubourg Saint-Denis on vend bijoux ça
rit mais long en cassette surtout en
langue tamoul il s'appelait dravidien de
Milan avant notre ère les tamoul ils
avaient comme aujourd'hui la peau sombre
et une civilisation
urbaine avancée arrive les arrières qui
tentent de les dominer mais les anciens
dieux sont malins ils avalent les
nouveaux la synthèse donnera naissance à
l'Inde régie depuis cette époque par le
système des quatre castes et jusqu'en
1950 système persistera mise en place
par l'ordre religieux des Brahman
monsieur vous travaillez en famille
[Musique]
vous êtes associés
et vous avez d'autres affaires ailleurs
et vous avez des affaires en Europe
aussi
[Musique]
vous envisagez juste rester en France à
Paris
vous êtes bien en France vous avez envie
de rester en France pourquoi
tu veux pas beaucoup à la française
on parlez pas bien le français
et puis
il y a d'autres raisons
parce que
je crois qu'il a une autre raison il va
peut-être nous dire pourquoi il veut
rentrer
le business ensemble avec les familles
pas la peine les personnages de d'autres
quelle est la différence entre la vie
que vous avez ici et la vie que vous
avez là-bas ce que vous n'avez pas ici
parce que tout est différent ça c'est
pas la même chose
et c'est pour ça je suis personnellement
pas d'accord avec la culture
vous pouvez me regarder un petit peu
merci
[Musique]
les nourritures
ces hommes qui se louent à leur ou à la
journée dans le sentier son épatestanais
est musulman ils ne sont plus indiens
depuis 1947 ici il travaille avec des
Hindous de l'île Maurice ou de Madras il
n'aime pas les Hindous dans leur
globalité et le disent mais le meilleur
ami est souvent quand même un hindou ou
allait comprendre réfugiés politiques
quelquefois ils sont venus surtout pour
échapper à une vie faite de contraintes
religieuse et sociales et surtout ils
veulent faire fortune alors direz-vous
les migrations indiennes et bien
difficile à cerner oui et ce n'est pas
tout faubourg Saint-Denis se retrouve la
plaque tournante des migrations
sri-lankaise à la pointe de l'Inde au
sud l'état du Sri Lanka au Sri Lanka un
gouvernement qui ne tolère plus la
présence de la population tamoul et
tente périodiquement de l'éliminer
physiquement
alors les jeunes s'enfuient on les
retrouve ici en région parisienne
madame tambie interprète auprès du
tribunal de Pontoise les aides souvent
dans les affaires de régularisation de
papier
ils sont arrivés le plus souvent par les
filiales clandestine de l'Est contre pas
mal d'argent d'autres sont venus par
l'Espagne et ils sont parqués dans les
foyers de banlieue attendant une
hypothétique solution il répondent à nos
questions
voulez-vous leur demander pour nous
pourquoi ils sont venus en France
mingel France déchets
ils sont venus en France parce que leur
vie était menacée en Sri Lanka pour
quelle raison
politique le gouvernement de Sri Lanka
essaye de éliminer les taméliens vivants
Sri Lanka alors ils se sentait menacés
ils ont quitté leur pays pourquoi
sont-ils venus en France
dans leur histoire que la France était
un beau pays les gens de France ils
étaient très gentils en plus le
gouvernement français ils étaient gentil
et garde gens comme réfugiés politiques
d'autre part ils ont des problèmes
psychologiques ils se sentent dépaysés
et orphelins ils sont pas bien assimilés
dans le vie sociale de français
plupart d'eux ils sont sans travail il
touche le allocation de chômage ils ont
ils se sont entrés par leur famille et
leurs amis et il vit en communauté dans
une chambre plusieurs de plusieurs
membres via ensemble combien sont-ils
dans ce foyer
ils sont 139 personnes ici
ce délégué c'est-il combien il y a
actuellement de tamouls en France
mille personnes comment le gouvernement
français les aide utile
commencer de leur arrivée leur donne
deux mois une prime de 1000 francs par
mois après leur versait une année de
prime de chômage ça veut dire la
location de chômage après il leur place
dans le dans un endroit où ils peuvent
apprendre à lire et écrire français et
si c'est possible une place dans un
entreprise pour apprendre certaines
métiers que penses-tu de quelques-uns de
leurs collègues qui trafiquent sur la
drogue
vivant à Paris ils se sont mêlés dans le
drogue mais parmi eux il y a pas de
personnes qui sont trafiquées le drogue
mais ils disent c'est leur situation
qu'il faut pousser à faire parce qu'ils
sont pas assez d'argent ils savent pas
comment vivre à ça la poussée à faire
telle chose
[Musique]
ils se sont très gênés et honteux de
fautes des autres ils disent à cause de
ces gens-là qui trafiquent le drogue
nous sommes mal bio en France et on se
sent très navré par cette situation
monsieur Tamby le chef de famille
origine Pondichéry policier français
affecté à Pontoise a vécu en Indochine
la plus grande partie de sa carrière
[Musique]
madame tambie a vécu toute sa jeunesse
entre Madras pour ni chéri et mysor ils
ont trois enfants
Sandrine 17 ans la petite dernière Marc
et Liliane Lainé
[Musique]
monsieur tomber sa famille et les
Indiens que nous allons rencontrer on
fait le choix culturel et sentimental de
vivre ici tout en préservant le ramadan
[Musique]
c'est la racine de curcuma et on les
utilise dans les plats en même temps on
les utilise pour faire du masque sur le
visage ça nettoie la peau et même temps
l'utilise la pâte de cette racine on
utilise pour badiger le fil ficelle
quand la pelle tali seulement les femmes
mariées qu'il utilise ça donc j'aimerais
bien que mes filles elles continuent à
vivre comme on a vécu jusqu'à là c'est
malgré un habitant en France je fais
beaucoup d'efforts pour sauvegarder nos
coutumes nos façons de vivre
elles comprennent elles sont très
heureux d'ambiance Harry cuisiner en
mode indienne souvent elles invitent
leurs copines elle prépare les plans
indiens et sont fiers de montrer
qu'elles sont indiennes à Nice en poudre
tu peux mettre un peu de
du sel pas beaucoup pour papa oui oui
voilà non encore un peu et oublie pas
l'ajouter quelques feuilles de carilips
feuilles de carie
Sandrine comme sa mère comme sa soeur
apprend pour se produire un jour dans
les spectacles de danse indienne
[Musique]
a beaucoup travaillé avec Maurice Béjart
aujourd'hui à l'enseigne à l'Unesco y
compris à chantala sa petite fille la
danse classique indienne
pour venir ici et j'ai repris tout mon
travail de danse pour danser pour les
occidentaux et aussi pour enseigner ça
m'a donné une question de être en plus
contact avec moi-même
nous retrouverons ce vitrineur et sa
famille
Sandrine vous avez je crois un autre
prénom oui mon deuxième prénom indien
c'est soundoris c'est un ami à moi qui
est venu à nous plutôt qui est venu
qui est venu des Indes et qui a décidé
de nommer comme ça car jusqu'à là je
n'avais pas de prénom indien alors
depuis ce temps là j'ai pris ce prénom
puis je crois que ça me va après tout et
puis je le garde beauté
est-ce que vous vous sentez aujourd'hui
une jeune fille indienne plus je grandis
puis faut dire que maintenant ça m'a
motivé d'aller en Inde je me sens plus
indienne maintenant j'ai je sens que
que j'appartiens à quelque chose que
j'appartiens à une religion une race
tandis que avant je n'y prêtais guère
attention du tout
j'étais plutôt française plutôt
française de la nature
marque Tamby il viendra technicien et
pour l'instant il préfère le rock à la
musique indienne
et si on vous demandait de maintenir un
choix entre choisir entre vivre là-bas
et où vivre en France ben moi je
resterai en France parce que déjà j'ai
la famille à connais pas pratiquement
pas et problème d'élan et déjà j'ai fait
toutes les études en français donc pour
me recycler dans quelle langue vous
recycler
parce que déjà je fais une section
technique alors ça ça va être un peu
plus dur quoi
vous pensez que ce serait le seul
handicap
j'ai une autre mentalité par rapport aux
gens vous pensez que le fossé vraiment
trop profond entre vous
non quand même pas non déjà j'ai la
couleur avez-vous le sentiment que si un
jour vous envisagez de vous marier ce
sera avec une indienne
[Musique]
qu'en pensez-vous parents ils savent que
je n'avais pas envie d'aller vivre
là-bas ah oui ils le savent déjà ils
nous ont demandé déjà par exemple
aucun des trois enfants ne suivra si ma
petite sœur peut-être qu'est-ce qui vous
retient en Inde qu'est-ce qui vous
a-t-il
le respect d'abord le respect que les
gens se portent mutuellement
la beauté du pays aussi et il y a toute
ma famille là-bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici on perd tout
ici ou dans n'importe quelle
capitale européenne ou pays européen
[Applaudissements]
vous envisagerez croyez-vous d'épouser
un indien des Indes un indien de France
ou l'homme qui vous plaira
un France j'aimerais ou un indien avec
une mentalité autre que la mentalité
indienne pourquoi je ne sais pas
la mentalité indienne serait plutôt que
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout à fait le contraire d'ici
c'est
l'homme indien aurait tendance à
considérer une femme comme un objet
comme comme la femme qui reste à la
maison comme
comme la femme qui s'occupe des enfants
tandis que un homme indien d'ici
peut-être qu'il aurait tout à fait une
autre mentalité peut-être le contraire
mais il aurait quand même une touche
indienne quelque chose d'indien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes contents toute la famille est
là aujourd'hui
toujours mais il va chercher
vous savez qu'il y a quelques années je
me bagarrer pour qu'ils partent qui
sortent pas hein
si c'était pas agréable
mais vous continuez de considérer que
vous filles doivent rester à la maison
je n'ai pas besoin maintenant ça me fait
rien maintenant
mais je souhaite quand même qui soit là
quoi papa c'est le père très positif
il veut nous garder comme ça simplement
ça se limite à la famille la maison
c'est tout comme maman c'était
complètement différent alors c'est
toujours été un moyen de friction mais
je veux dire que j'ai pas une
adolescence complètement différente des
autres filles non
vous avez quitté la maison oui
mais c'est un bon
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à travailler à Paris pour
moi ça m'a posé un très gros problème je
veux dire de me déplacer de Pontoise à
Paris c'était quand même quelque chose
d'énorme parce que je devais me lever
très très tôt le matin rentrer le soir
vu le trajet vu le travail ça me
fatiguait bon il y a eu ça qui a joué
puis d'autres petits problèmes qui sont
ajoutés par la suite comment avez-vous
ressenti le départ de votre fille
moi ça a été très dur j'ai failli avoir
une crise cardiaque d'ailleurs
pour nous parce que ça a été très dur
pour mon épouse aussi qui a eu des
problèmes de santé aussi
ignorent ces problèmes là mais c'est
surtout parce que dans les familles
indiennes ça ne se fait pas oui dans
chez nous les filles elles nous quittent
pas tant que chez nous les filles sont
considérés comme un joyeux comme un
bijou en transmet précieusement à
leur futur mari elle quitte le jour elle
se marie c'est ça c'est c'est malgré on
essaye d'adapter
mode de vie français au fond de
nous-mêmes on a resté beaucoup à lundi
on a resté avec nos principes nos
coutumes ça restait en nous vos enfants
ont été élevés en France et sont nés en
France
quel est levée en France
et cependant vous allez repartir en Inde
vous allez les laisser ici
on envisage mais c'est un drame qui va
se jouer et on aura un sacré quatre
conscience les laisser
quand ils sont bien établis tout de
suite
on recherche la nuit comment pour
la vie matérielle pas pour autre chose
vous voulez dire qu'en Inde elle aura
des serviteurs
d'adopter un couple d'orphelin pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a beaucoup même temps on peut leur
aider à vivre convenable
alors faire arriver dans la vie vous
voyez mais en fait vous avez la
nostalgie de l'Inde bien sûr j'ai
grandi tout ça en Inde
j'ai encore souvenir de mon enfance
adolescent et jeunesse
pour moi ça fera du bien parce que ça
sera une vie sereine
en levant une autre façon on peut
toujours reporter au lendemain ce qu'on
ne fait pas la veille
dans le roman que vedia publie ses
jours-ci déjà nous sommes pris dans les
boucles de la longue chevelure de Ganga
le Gange fleuve déesse déjà
[Musique]
où nous souhaitions aller au plus
profond de la made in
oui c'est chouette d'être à Paris et
tout ça mais en même temps elle est en
nostalgique quelque part et je crois
comment on vit c'est à travers
l'écriture à travers des
de l'imagination qui donne sur notre
propre pays le Gange quand on parle de
la gorge pour moi c'est
c'est croyances quelque chose qui est né
avec l'enfant dès qu'on est né le maire
nous parle de qui était Ganga c'était
quoi l'histoire de mabarta c'est comment
était une femme alors le fait que Ganga
était une femme ça descend le mythe de
déesse un peu sur la terre même parce
que là on arrive à voir que c'était
quelqu'un aussi aimable que que
n'importe qui on peut rencontrer dans la
vie et au même
au même niveau il y a un aspect mythique
de choses et je crois c'est le mélange
de dos que
qui constitue le mythe Nandini est-ce
que je le fleuve grand je représente
encore quelque chose d'important dans
l'inconscient collectif indien
absolument vous voyez ça cette vase ça
vient de gauche
et ça a toujours été dans la maison
ça marque une pèlerinage chaque famille
fait cette pèlerinage et
il y avait quelqu'un dans ma famille qui
m'a apporté ça rempli de l'eau de gorge
et ça on garde dans nos maisons au cas
où on me alors il faut avoir une goutte
d'eau
pourquoi
sa purifie avant de mourir
et
c'est un souvenir il a son nom la date
de pèlerinage tout marquée et cette
image de la déesse Gong ici on l'appelle
la mère-gorge
l'eau était sombre dans le calme souris
d'une nuit parisienne j'ai brusé une
noix de coco sur un caillou pour que son
esprit puisse échapper à la vanité du
solvant du monde noix de coco et
guirlande 20 millions école bracelet et
nappes tout ce qui était son Éros et sa
promesse d'amour de tout lancer sur la
scène avec la foi absolue que tous les
fleuves qu'on disait à Ganga
la mythologie indienne a survécu à tous
les avatars de la colonisation la
mythologie continue d'envahir l'Inde
d'abord et c'est vrai parce que le mythe
a commencé par exemple je prends
l'exemple de Ganga de gorge
on a vu d'abord c'était très religieux
et Kanga est quand même une femme même
dans le mythe très séductrice tout ça
avec Shiba avec baguire elle joue
beaucoup de séduction mais ce qui arrive
à mon imagination là tout de suite c'est
un homme que j'avais rencontré sur le
rive de Ganges quand je faisais la
descente du fleuve alors il m'a vendu un
pampellé pour 50 personnes à 50 centimes
quelque chose j'étais étonné j'ai vu le
Gange elle descendait des cieux comme ça
elle avait des soutiens
soutien-gorge plus petit comme ça et des
anges vraiment
entre guillemets sexy et elle venait pas
de cire elle venait de bomber des
saignement de bomber et moi je lui ai
demandé il a dit voilà mais ça c'était
Ganga écoutez est-ce que vous avez vu
les grands épopées indiennes est-ce que
vous avez vu la description de Ganga il
a dit oui mais ça va bien très bien ce
jour-ci alors c'est quand même la vie
d'un mythe à travers je crois des images
de la actuelle mais c'est une mythologie
qui nourrit l'imagination indienne
est-ce qu'elle éloigne pas un peu de la
réalité quotidienne absolument beaucoup
c'est beaucoup en fait mais c'est la
réalité on a je me demande si on peut
poser la question comme ça c'est très ce
qui te soigner que la réalité on a un
côté il a le royaume des croyances on
pense que c'est les gens sont piaule
tout ça mais en même temps on voit les
habits de tous ces gens là c'est les
marchands et les épiciers c'est les gens
qui qui font tout ce qui fait le monde
aujourd'hui exploitation la vie normale
comment marche le vie et
l'oppression d'autres gens et je crois
c'est une sorte mélange de deux il y a
une mythologie très ampoulée dans la
tête des gens mais en même temps la vie
est aussi moderne ou matérialiste ici
ça n'empêche pas l'action
c'est ça le magie de la d'aujourd'hui
qu'elle est en croyance d'un côté
matérialisme l'autre il y a une sorte de
contradiction mais en même temps les
deux vont très bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non d'ini méta et journaliste dans un
grand quotidien de délit elle a suivi
son mari diplomate à Paris et nous a
découvert avec un durgence
je ne savais pas grand chose sur la
France je ne savais pas un mot de
français
mais j'avais
vécu à l'étranger à l'Occident avant
et je trouvais bien sûr vous étiez très
différents
j'ai trouvé le mentalité française
beaucoup
plus proche que le nôtre de notre par
exemple dans le pays anglo-saxon on se
sent vraiment à l'étranger
c'est une grande différence
qu'est-ce qui fait que nous sommes
proches
par exemple vous avez des
liens familiaux très serrés comme nous
les Français sont très individuels
listes comme les Indiens les Indiens
il faut garder l'individualisme je crois
c'est très important
et
vous voyez on a un dossier en accepte
pas il n'y a pas de cette acceptation
aveugle d'autorité on aime les petits
tricheries on a notre système D comme
vous avez fait
[Musique]
vous appartenait à une famille qui a
encore je crois le respect des casques
comme beaucoup d'autres Indiens en Inde
oui
respect ou simplement le fait que nous
sommes nous vivons comme ça pas
simplement le respect nous le vivons
aussi dans la vie
mais ça diminue déjà regardez ma fille
elle ne sait pas qu'est-ce que c'est la
case parce qu'elle vit ici c'est dans
mon esprit et dans mon psychose qui se
passe parce que dans ma maison de
famille
il y avait les casques qui avait le
droit d'entrer dans quel portier
jusqu'au quel est mon père même n'était
pas de même casse tout ça c'est marqué
comme en France de quelqu'un c'était
utile votre père il était vraiment
et votre mère
[Musique]
le deuxième
ça changeait quelque chose dans la vie
dans la maison qu'il ne soit pas de la
même caste évidemment
mais pour moi c'était pas bizarre si
vous voulez si je vous disais que mon
père mangeait pas avec moi et je n'avais
pas le droit de le toucher avant qu'il a
terminé son dîner et qu'il est d'une
façon souillée pour jusque lendemain si
vous voulez son puretés et à par rapport
aux autres cases n'étaient pas
strictement observé jusque le lendemain
où il a pris son bain et il a recommencé
sa journée alors après le dîner on avait
le droit de le tracé d'être avec lui
et vous ne ressentiez pas cela comme une
restriction
[Musique]
maintenant je la vois comme ça votre
mère
ma mère avec eux ça toute sa vie moi au
moins j'ai perdu mon père quand j'étais
très petite mais ma mère l'a vécu toute
sa vie comme ça et pour elle c'était
tellement naturelle
[Musique]
mais en tout cas les notions de pureté
c'est une notion profonde dans l'esprit
indienne l'un prendra des années d'être
vraiment débarrassé parce que même
les filles actuellement qui cherche un
mari cherche dans leur caste
alors le coutume continue même pour les
gens d'éduquer de
scientifiques d'autres c'est donc une
notion que vous rapportez à la religion
à la spiritualité ah oui la plus
perfectionnée le plus des tâches et le
plus de hors de tout c'est qu'on
tirerait les plus belles et rechercher
noble mais des gens qui sont classés qui
étaient classés qu'ils sont encore comme
intouchables
était un pur c'était un peu parce qu'il
faisait le travail un peu
et pendant mon esprit c'est par rapport
au moins et ce que je fais c'est un pur
c'est tout mais par rapport au même
d'une certaine façon il ne pouvait pas
sortir de leur casque
comme ici peut-être de fils d'un boucher
peut être coiffeur maintenant je ne sais
pas un intouchable actuellement est un
ministre
Alain est obligé de le toucher
alors que dans la vie politique ou
économique ça passe pas dans la même
manière mais dans l'esprit c'est une
source de souffrance pour le brame que
de toucher ou d'être touché par un
impure plus que souffrance je me
souviens d'un père prêtre drama de mon
village il venait souvent voir ma mère
dans ma maison et en route
si vous voyez un intouchable il avait un
parapluie toujours pour ne pas être vu
par l'intouchable et si par hasard il
parlait l'intouchable et il entendait il
commençait à pleurer mais vraiment
il avait une notion qu'il était
tellement souillé par ça il savait pas
comment purifier lui-même je me souviens
très bien
quelle distance existe entre
les femmes de la caste supérieure et les
autres
est-ce qu'il y a une distance ou est-ce
qu'elle se rencontre est-ce qu'elles
peuvent aujourd'hui se rencontrer se
parler elles peuvent très bien se
rencontrer aujourd'hui par exemple quand
j'étais à l'école ou à l'université il y
avait pas mal de
filles de intouchables mais ils étaient
les filles de deuxième génération mais
par exemple dans les grandes villes
comme des lits
il y a un autre façon de rencontrer des
femmes intouchables ce sont eux qui font
un travail essentiel et elles viennent
de maisons en maison pour ramasser les
ordures
et ce sont des femmes qui
qui ont été obligés de travailler depuis
longtemps pour gagner leur vie pour et
pour faire ce travail que personne
d'autre ne veut pas faire
et je les ai toujours trouvé très libéré
très vivable
avec de très belles et sans le
inhibition que nous les femmes comme
moi-même
des familles bourgeoises
nous sommes plus opprimés par les
traditions si vous voulez et des
couteaux quelle sorte d'inhibition
une forte comportement quand on le sort
il faut s'effacer beaucoup
elle ne parlez pas devant les autres
n'importe pas de maquillage
il faut s'effacer
quand on sort et c'est facile aussi
devant les hommes c'est surtout devant
les hommes
je pense que vous avez apparaît les amis
indiennes oui bien sûr comment
peuvent-elles s'adapter à la vie
française
je crois les femmes qui viennent ici
plutôt sont surtout
du Nord sont surtout déjà d'une couche
sociale qui est assez élevée et ça c'est
les gens qui adaptent tout de suite à
Paris mais qui radapte en Inde beaucoup
plus difficilement 3 ans après parce que
je crois à Paris quand même le grand don
qu'il donne aux femmes ici c'est la
liberté on a de la femme n'est pas libre
les contrôler
d'après le grand maître de la loi
personnelle hindou Manou une figure
mythique il a dit les femmes doit
toujours protégée par soit son mari soit
le fils soit le père alors ici il a dit
Marie ni le pain ni le fils alors elle
est libre
sa vitrine vous êtes une indienne
peut-être un peu plus libre que toutes
les autres indiennes
parce que vous venez d'une région
où le système est matriarcal
oui le mari est au second plan je dirais
pas mais ça semble pour vous
pour moi c'est tellement naturel c'est
qu'il est c'est que mon frère est pour
moi mais pour vous peut-être un peu
bizarre
quels sont les avantages qui sont liés à
la transmission du nom et des biens pour
une femme pour une femme c'est une
certaine idée une sécurité
[Musique]
une fête que ses enfants par exemple
s'il y a deux maris il n'y a pas de
différence entre les enfants si vous
voulez c'est le traitement parce que
c'est la base c'est la mer
[Rires]
en nous présente l'Inde comme un pays
d'une autre spiritualité et cependant la
dot semble jouer un rôle fondamental
mais vous savez nous sommes devenus
une société de consommation dans les
grandes villes
on a cette envie d'avoir d'acheter des
choses comme la télévision
réfrigérateurs les choses comme ça
et la date est devenue plus exigée
n'a pas été assez importante sont
rejetées et parfois même disparaissent
complètement de la famille
malheureusement c'est vrai
je ne veux pas cacher ces choses là mais
ça arrive dans les grandes villes et
dans un certain milieu de le classe
moyenne si vous voulez ça n'arrive pas
dans le village
ou
que deviennent-elles ces femmes
elles se brûle souvent
parce que elles sont si désespérées pour
n'avoir pas apporté à cette dentelle
sont humiliés par la famille la belle
famille et c'est vrai ça arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait quelqu'un qui qui a pris
100000 francs pour pour le premier dot
et dans un an on a trouvé qu'ils ont
arrosé la femme dans la cuisine avec
héros saine la brûlé et déclarer à tout
le monde que c'est un accident c'était
le petit machin plaque qui a s'explosé
quelque chose comme ça et dans deux ans
il s'est remarié avec une autre date de
100.000 francs alors c'est devenu une
industrie ou quoi
[Musique]
c'est un cas vraiment triste dans un ce
qui se passe maintenant et c'est assez
répandu en toutes les femmes sont
menacées pas toutes les femmes se
menacées toutes les femmes sont menacées
certainement avec les angulades tout ça
que tu n'as pas ramener un scooter ou
taxi ou un télévision ou frigo mais les
dotes les meurtres à cause de d'autres
sont beaucoup plus rares mais assez pour
nous inquiéter
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
c'est un question un peu difficile d'un
côté on a fait beaucoup de progrès
vous comme vous savez on a eu un Premier
ministre qui est femme et ce qui ce que
Gandhi a fait il a
emmené beaucoup de femmes dans le lutte
contre
le colonialisme et grâce à ça on a
toujours eu beaucoup de femmes dans la
vie politique et ça continue toujours
aussi
à peu près 46% de des étudiants en Inde
sont des femmes
ils ont tout l'occasion de
avoir un profession même le plus plus
haut position et ça continue très bien
mais à l'autre côté on a cette système
de dirt cette
tyrannie dans la famille
qui est très dur pour la femme quand
elle n'a pas sa dépendance et économique
c'est ça qui va changer les choses
[Musique]
il est entré dans cette famille à l'âge
de 12 ans en Inde aujourd'hui intendant
confident il va repartir se marier à
Noël dans son pays son frère le
remplacera ici
[Musique]
dans la vie de couple entre la vie d'un
couple indien et d'un couple français
la famille
les enfants les parents l'entourage tout
ça qui est important donc ici vous êtes
arrivés vous étiez étudiants vous étiez
jeune vous vous êtes retrouvés avec deux
enfants c'est une petite famille oui
mais heureusement nous avons retrouvé
beaucoup de sœurs et frères et France
qui sont quand même remplacés notre
famille vraiment par exemple nous sommes
mariés chez un ami qui était
le oncle maternel pour moi parce que
c'est l'homme qui maternelle qui fait le
mariage de fille dans le système matière
nous nous sommes mariés chez un ami
qui fait un peu notre
entourage intime
la vie religieuse dans la vie
quotidienne tient d'une grande place
la vie quotidienne
ça fait partie de la naissance jusqu'à
la mort
qu'est-ce que c'est que
la vie intérieure qui s'exprime par les
différentes formes
de
méditation de prière
d'une certaine côté morale certaines
modifications
dans la religion parce qu'ils sont
pénétrés de cette religion mais est-ce
que vous avez des difficultés à les
maintenir
je pense pas qu'il y a des difficultés
certainement ils sont certainement
influencés par ce qu'ils entendent à
l'école pas l'intermédiaire copains par
les maîtresses l'école ces professeurs
etc mais ça ne veut pas dire que
l'intérieur de la maison on a la
possibilité de pratiquer autre chose
première chose deuxièmement ils vont en
tous les ans
c'est à peu près deux mois tous les ans
et ma fille pratique le danse qui est
déjà un peu sacrée et mon fils pratique
le violon à l'indienne qui aussi est des
chansons qui font des loges de Dieu et
puis le soir quand il se couche sa mère
raconte des histoires qui sont tirées
des livres sacrés de l'Inde qui permet
d'assimuler d'un côté la mode de vie de
la mythologie into et de l'autre côté à
faire un esprit ouvert en fait chez nous
l'indice reconnaît que le Dieu peut
apparaître dans tous les formes
soit je souffrir
il n'y a pas de différence c'est qui
différencie les ventous c'est leur mode
de vie de reconnaître cette
multitude de façon dans laquelle on peut
approcher
l'idéal de Dieu c'est l'idéal
[Musique]
tu es le soleil tu es la lune tu es le
vent tu es le feu tu es les os tu es le
ciel tu es la terre tu es l'âme du monde
les mots des sages voile ta nature
ici-bas nous ignorons ce que tu es mais
nous savons que tu es cela
[Musique]